-Thanks to newly developed
technology,
we here at "Late Night"
now have the ability
to record the tiny voice that
is inside Donald Trump's head.
And you might be surprised
to know
that like everyone's
inner voice,
Donald Trump is filled with
paralyzing fear and self-doubt
and is easily distracted.
So here is the tiny voice in
the back of Donald Trump's head.
♪♪♪♪
[ Applause ]
-Okay, Donald.
It's the tiny voice in the back
of your head reminding you
not to lose the Queen,
no matter what you do.
Don't let her out of your --
Oh, no.
Where is the Queen?
Oh, where is the Queen?
Oh, okay, there she is.
Now just lumber alongside her.
Don't talk to her
or look at her.
Perfect.
Very presidential.
Look at these guys.
Look like nutcrackers.
[ Laughter ]
What's on their heads?
Are those big furry hats,
or are they afros?
Hats or afros.
It's hard to tell.
They're probably hats.
But they look a lot like afros.
Whenever you ask,
they don't answer.
So I guess you're going to
leave England not knowing.
One of life's many mysteries,
Donald.
One of life's many mysteries.
Oh, there's a little guy
at the end.
♪♪♪♪